good on him or some well done you're
shameless and I love that about you
hi lad Bible it's Andy Serkis here and
I'm here to answer any of your questions
yeah woody and I bonded we became sort
of bonded in wine really
we became sort of we spent many a night
quaffing very nice wine and yeah we had
it we had some great times become really
close mates and he is a he is definitely
a lad is all I can say
aller not necessarily male could be
female could be anything depending where
you want to be on the spectrum but a lad
is like somebody's genuine lad is you
know it means well he's got is honorable
and fun and doesn't suffer fools but can
see both sides of an argument that's
such a difficult question because there
have been some great experiences I mean
obviously Lord of the Rings it was an
incredible journey because it was the
first time of using this technology
using performance capture technology and
playing such a great character and
Gollum has been a big part of my life
obviously so there are some very very
happy memories from shooting in New
Zealand over the course not only
actually Lord the Rings but then going
back and shooting King Kong there and
then going back and directing the second
unit on The Hobbit trilogy as well as
reprising Gollum I thought good on you
my son well done you're shameless and I
love that about you try to avoid doing
Gollum anymore I've made a decision and
it's like only on very very rare
occasions we
dawn click on invoice I think it's time
I think I matured to a point now where
I'd like to leave it there's a magical
magical time a magical character that I
can wave goodbye to I think I need to
you're always putting part of yourself
under under the microscope when you play
a character no matter how extreme you
know if it's golem or King Kong or Ian
Dury or any any of the any of the
characters I've played along the way
you're always searching for that at that
point of connection with Caesar I think
it I always thought that he was an
outsider played him as an outsider
neither ate nor human but somewhere in
between and I suppose that that is part
of you know my you know my sense of
growing up and who I am is always sort
of observing from the agent and but but
with that having the ability to to be
empathetic to different peoples
different cultures different societies
to create the character of Caesar over
the course of these last three movies
there have been lots of different
variations and ways of getting into the
character because when I was playing him
in Rise which is the first movie he's
very much more chimp-like and then of
course he evolves over the course of the
the subsequent two movies in war he is
now this leader that is more human-like
in his emotions in his physicality in in
the way that he expresses himself with
language and so on so with each step
along the way of these three films there
have been different processes and ways
of getting into character from being
much more physical and chimp-like at the
beginning to actually basing him on a
real leader of a society which was what
the second film dawn was about well King
Kong is just such an amazing story
brilliant epic kind of adventure and
love story and that was I suppose Kong
was my first proper leading romantic
lead character and that was great fun to
play
despite the fact he's a 25-foot gorilla
the it was really incredible playing
opposite Naomi what she was just
extraordinary actress and and I think
you know being able to play those scenes
you know they're they're sort of
tenderness and affection towards each
other you know with the obviously
difference in scale it was it was it was
a really incredible job and Caesar
Caesar I really have loved as a
character playing him all the way
through from infancy to you know
throughout the whole of his life and
that's one of the great things about
performance capture technology which is
it allowing an actor to be able to do
that and and when else would an act to
get the opportunity to play the entire
life of a character from birth to death
I can't think really of any other actor
that maybe has ever done that